so this is my entire defense is that if
I were to burn my house down I guarantee
you my husband would be in it there's no
way I would go to all that trouble and
then have nothing to show for it
[Music]
you guys know where's the host of my
wife makes me podcast just with her
husband please give it up for Miss
Bonnie McFarlane everybody four years
ago my house burned down to the ground I
lost everything
and I fell into a depression so deep I
didn't know if I would ever get out of
it so naturally I thought this would be
a funny story to tell on television I
before I used to tell this story that I
have to say there's a little bit of
ongoing legal battle
so yeah I'm being sued by some of the
adjoining town houses and the entire
town house Association so my lawyer
strongly suggested that I begin with the
disclaimer so I just want to make it
really clear I did not willingly or
negligently burn my house down
but if I did do it this is how I would
do it now my husband wasn't home my
husband was all the way across the
country we live in in New Jersey and
yeah I mean you can make fun of it if
you want but let me just say this at
least once sometimes twice a day I'm the
hottest person wherever I'm at I've been
here less than 24 hours I feel like
so we're living in New Jersey my
husband's all the way across the country
he's performing stand-up across the
country and I'm just at home alone with
my daughter when my house burns down and
so this is my entire defense is that if
I were to burn my house down I guarantee
you my husband would be in it
there's no way I would go to all that
trouble and then have nothing to show
for it so it's just my dot I would never
endanger my daughter she's my world
she's my everything she's like five or
eight or something like that
and now I love her so much on the
weekends know if something bad Eirene
happen I would just I would really miss
her around the big holidays so so my
daughter in our home at that time she
was about four years old and it was
about 10 o'clock at night and I put in a
movie for her I know if you're a parent
you're judging me right now it's like in
my own way we're horror I'll start
watching a movie it's like we stayed up
late you know then we slept in we got a
plate cuz at that time my daughter did
not have a job so let me just say this -
we'd been smelling smoke since about 4
o'clock that afternoon until about three
weeks after the fire it really gets in
it's pervasive so I just what am I gonna
do I just was like okay fine I put in
her movie The Little Mermaid which she
loves she's seen that movie so much
she's seen that she's watched that movie
more times than the guy who edited it
and then I next to her on the bed was
this is the most embarrassing part of
the story I was doing tarot cards I'm
not into that I'm not into the occult or
anything not it like I'm just I'm a
normal guy only done like maybe like to
vision boards in my life like I'm not
that kind of person but you know as a
parent parenting is like very rewarding
in small doses and then there's like
long stretches of the Little Mermaid so
I was just totally focused on my future
and then my daughter was like mommy look
and the patio windows in my bedroom were
just completely awash in flames there
was so bright it was crazy that I didn't
notice it because I was like so focused
on my future
not my immediate future but I was like
looking ahead the thing I know it's
ironic like I'm looking at tarot cards
while my house is burning to the ground
but to be fair you know there's no like
hey it look to your left card so my
daughter was like we got to get out of
here and I was like you're bossy then I
grabbed my phone I ran out you know at
some point I check to see my daughter
was with me she was and as we're leaving
we see my neighbor walking up the steps
to go to her unit but she's moving it
really like she's moving so slow like
she just ate a handful of valiums she's
just like moving up going up to her unit
I go hey there's a fire she goes yeah I
know I just called 9-1-1 that's it great
have fun up there so spoiler she makes
it she's one of the people suing me but
um she the care cats two cats they
didn't make it
Hey I would have moved quicker if I was
her is that my fault that she was like
you know let's get a move on so I do
feel that I mean I felt bad about it you
know I'm a vegetarian I get it I mean I
would never eat cats anyway but I mean
you know you care so I call my husband
and he was about to go onstage and I was
like oh my gosh I freaked out and then
he freaked out then he realized there's
nothing he could do so he was like well
I mean I'm got it I'm gonna go do my
show because that's how messed up
comedians are they'll just go on you
know just something bad happens you just
go do your show in it you just go make
people like I had a miscarriage right
before this and I just compartmentalize
I said no you go out there you deal with
that later these people want to laugh so
I do that for you here well ago and so
anyway so okay so then oh it was a
five-alarm fire which means there was
five different fire unit stations
whatever houses were there which I
didn't know that's what five-alarm meant
I just always thought it was a level of
spiciness so that was an interesting
thing to learn and then we're standing
across the street and we're just
watching our house burned down to the
ground and then my daughter suddenly it
dawns on her she's like are my stuffed
animals gonna make it and I was like no
honey they're not and she just started
bawling so hard I felt it was
heartbreaking so any time we'll replace
those stuffed animals any time you want
to stuffed animal I would get you a
stuffed animal and then cut to four
years later we have what can only be
described as a stuffed animal problem so
then after the house burned down the
detective came out there was a guy who
watched too much law and order you know
came over it started question I mean I
guess we've all watched too much law and
order I guess that's what unifies us as
humans you know we've just all seen too
many law and orders but he was like
really into it
and so then he interrogated me for a
while and I was like hey back off
Stabler
well excited and then I guess his
working theory was that I'd been smoking
pot on my balcony because I guess the
tarot cards people were like why else
would you do tarot cards so he thought I
was on my balcony smoking pot and then I
just said to him you know how hard it is
to keep a joint lit and then he was like
oh right and so then I just I just got
to go they were like okay that's that I
guess so but then I called my husband
and I was like well you know we've lost
everything it's it's over and my husband
was at the airport at this time you know
he's finished his show and everything
and he said to me I just had the best
show I've ever had
so that was but some good came out of it
and we didn't actually lose everything
they just only recovered the Little
Mermaid DVD so thank God we saw that you
guys had a lot of fun thank you very
much
[Applause]
you